Hey youtubers it’s charlie, I hope you had
an awesome thanksgiving.
Since we’ve already gotten some really good
info on Legend Of Korra Book 3 and Michael
Dante DiMartino and Bryan Koneyetzko have
kind of given their own post-morten thoughts
on Book 2 I thought I’d do a video explaining
the Top 5 things about book 2 that will change
in book 3 along with an overall review of
the episodes.
So quick update on where everything is in
terms of production right now.
As of New York Comic Con this year Book 3
was in the middle of being animated and the
writing on book 4 was finished.
The episodes for both books have already been
ordered from Nickelodeon.
So regardless of future ratings, we’ll see
both books.
Book 3 in 2014 and Book 4 in 2014.
I’ll talk more about release dates in a
future video.
Currently they haven’t made any announcement
on when book 3 will premiere.
So let’s dive in to Book 3 changes.
Here’s the top 5 biggest changes coming.
Number 5 - No more teenage Romance.
Dimartino said that because fans got so upset
every time they tried to do a teenage romance
subplots, none of the story in book 3 would
focus on that.
At the end of book 2 Korra and Mako are finished
and Book 3 picks up a couple weeks after the
end of book 2, so the wounds from their breakup
will still be pretty fresh, but if it is referenced
it will only be very briefly.
So if you hated all the Makorra Masami stuff
you are in luck.
Number 4 - Earth Kingdom.
So remember the avatar cycle.
It was a big part of Avatar Wan learning all
the bending styles and it directly influences
which tribe each new avatar is born in.
So far we started with Air, the water in book
2, so you can expect a lot of the story in
book 3 to deal with the earth kingdom and
ultimately back to fire for book 4.
Number 3 - Lots more Bumi and Lin Beifong.
Bumi isn’t a bender, but DiMartino and Konyetzko
already confirmed that there will be tons
more Bumi.
But book 2 really didn’t include a lot of
Biefong and we still have no idea who her
father is.
There’s no guarantee that Book 3 will reveal
that secret, but because it’s an earth book
she will be a much more central to the story
outside of team avatar.
Number 2 - Korra will still be spiritually
cut off from the previous avatars.
And the changes to the world at the end of
book 2 will stick.
Meaning the spirits will be freely inhabiting
the physical realm.
The interesting thing about this is that spirits
genuinely are immortal, so Korra can still
get the wisdom of ancient spirits, just not
the previous avatars.
So Iroh can still give her guidance.
But I don’t think he’s going to be re-joining
team avatar every single week.
If you’re still confused about the whole
thing, Korra can still learn things about
the past avatars.
She’ll just be experiencing them through
other people’s memories.
Like when your friend tells you about something
your other friend did.
She just won’t automatically be able to
recall things in her memory unless she learned
them before raava was destroyed.
and number 1 - The central conflict will not
revolve around Korra’s bending abilities.
At the end of book 2 Korra learns to energy
bend.
That’s not going to change in book 2.
So her ability to defeat the villains won’t
depend on her bending prowess.
Book 3 will be a much more existential story.
If you saw thor the dark world, loki tells
thor.
You can’t solve all your problems with hitting.
It will be the same situation in book 3.
This is just the next step to Korra becoming
a fully actualized avatar.
Wouldn’t it be crazy though if Korra became
the perfect avatar by the end of book 3 and
then in Book 4 another 100 year war started?
I don’t think that’s going to happen but
it does make you wonder…
As a side note too, both DiMartino and Konyetzko
said that after book 4 there would be no more
new avatar shows.
They’re so fried from working constantly
for the last several years that they’re
going to take a long break from the world
of avatar.
Book 4 is still at least 15-18 months away,
so a lot can still change to make them reconsider
though.
But Book 4 will be designed as a series finale,
not just a season finale.
With regards to some of the bigger changes
they’re making I actually think that they’re
all really positive.
It makes sense that they wouldn’t just keep
bringing back the same types of challenges.
Korra mastered the physical realm, so the
only way to keep the story fresh is to do
a much more existential journey.
Korra basically has to learn what it means
to be the avatar without the benefit of all
the other avatars and she has to help the
world learn how to live with spirits.
But now that we know all these things let
me know what you’re most excited to see
in book 3, who are you hoping they bring back
from last airbender and what are your final
thoughts on book 2?
I’ll be doing some fun Korra videos in the
next couple of weeks.
be sure to subscribe to get them.
There won’t be any more mega book 3 announcements
for the rest of the year, so I’ll just be
doing fun bonus videos.
I’m also still figuring out which new anime
series to do videos for.
One of the biggest suggestions has been fairy
tale, and I’m already doing attack on titan
as soon as it comes back.
But I’ll try to keep you posted on what
I decide.
Right now click here to watch my review of
the book 2 finale and click here to for my
game of thrones season 4 joffrey video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High fives!